تقول الحكمه في بلادي ثلج روسيا الانسان
في الحب ليس سيدا والحب اعمى لدرجه ان بعض
العاشقين يقعون في شباك المظلمه تترك اثرا
لا تمحوه السنون الطوال فتيات كثيرات
عندما يتعرفن الى الشباب يصعب عليهن
الوصول الى مشاعر الرجل وشخصيته الحقيقيه
المختبئه خلف اقنعه الحب والرومانسيه
والانا المتعجرفه بغرور مرحله قاسيه خلال
فتره التعارف تلاحظ فيها المراه ان الرجل
يحبها صباحا ويكرهه ظهرا ويبرر ويعتذر
مساءا انه الرجل السام في العلاقه او
الرجل
الرجل الطوكسك اسمه يطلق على الرجل الخلطه
من سحر متعب لعقل الانثى وعدوانيه مفرطه
باسباب مختلفه وتنمر على اوصافها وسيطره
المطلقه على حركتها وسكنتها
[موسيقى]
العشق حاله الساحره من المشاعر الجميله
اغمض عينيك واتبعني حتى ان بعض المحبين
يرون في الشتاء ربيعا بين ان السؤال
المفصليه هنا كيف يمكن معرفه مشاعر الرجل
الحقيقيه ان كانت صديقه بالفعل او
استغلالتان تحت قناعن مو زياف
حسب راي الخبراء لابد للمراه خلال فتره
التعارف من الانتباه لعده امور ابرزها
يكمن في ان يسود العقل على القلب في اتخاذ
القرارات عندما تشعر المراه بضعف في
تصرفاتها تبعا لحيائها ومشاعرها الرقيقه
ينصح الخبراء بعدم الانجراف وراء رغبه
الرجل والتخلي عن الطاعه العمياء ولابد من
معرفه ان الرجل السامه هو شخصيه مشوهه
فكريه ومريض عقليا ومزعزع الثقه بنفسه
ويحمل من الصراع بداخله ما يكفي لقتل كل
مشاعر المراه واحاسيسها وشخصيتها والتي
تعد ملكه جمال المخلوقات في الكون عبد
الجواد لصباح العربيه موسكو